in january it's time for new beginnings
and that's like
making changes to your diet it's the
fourth annual
las vegas vegan dining month and bianca
holman
is live in the eight news now kitchen
with details on maybe how we can lose a
few of those pandemic pounds
good morning bianca hey good morning
sherry you know gone are the days of
when we think of going vegan means just
eating a salad or only tofu and
wheatgrass shots no there's a variety of
things out there on the market from
breads cheese eggs sour cream and yes
this is all from my fridge
and trust me it's pretty good so it is
the fourth annual las vegas vegan
dining month and this is a guide to help
you explore more vegan options during
the month of the january so this was all
started to make
vegan options more accessible to folks
it makes the challenge on taking
uh on veganism more easier
restaurants like ariela's kosher and
pizza kitchen opened in fall of 2019
after seeing a need for dairy kosher
food and vegan comfort food
they are vegan pizza philly cheesesteaks
their milkshakes
oh yeah it satisfied it satisfies the
most self-proclaimed
meat eaters a lot of people become very
ambitious to
go vegan plant-based
and i think it's important to show them
that it's accessible
that it's a lot easier
than a lot of people make it out to be
and even in the midst of the pandemic 25
vegas based restaurants
are ready to serve you ariella's pizza
and kosher kitchen that's in the
northwest part of the valley
bronze cafe honey salt tacotarian
and some of the proceeds also benefit a
progressive leadership alliance
of nevada organization and this is a
group that focuses on social and
environmental justice here
in nevada so again if you plan to
participate this is just the menu here
at arielas and you can see they have a
variety of options and this is just an
example of one of the restaurants
that's participating just go ahead and
hashtag it you know instagram your food
and hashtag vegan vegan air hold on i
can't even say it but this is
the january there you go the january i'm
gonna send it back to you guys in the
studio
it's a hard one anywhere i'm so glad
i'm so glad i didn't have to say that
when i was talking to
bianca i was like oh please don't make
me say that word be january i guess it's
not as bad
no january you know alex uh
obviously you and sherry both uh are
subscribed to or don't have really a
choice to some extent to eat that way
it's not easy but it's it's doable i
think that's the
the lesson from bianca's story is that
it and it's healthier obviously
yeah and it's so nice a lot of our local
restaurants are really good about
labeling stuff they can make
adjustments really easily so thankfully
we have a lot of options i know back in
the day
when you had to do this especially if
you did gluten free
nate tapioca flour bread is not the
greatest
so we've come a long way on all these
fronts i am so
pleased that i was able to find for both
you and sherry though gluten-free
pretzels that actually are snappier and
crunchier
than some of the regular pretzels